und kommt im herbst das killer virus wie
der gesundheitsminister prophezeit was
haben die massiven grundrechtseingriff
ungen gebracht lockdown schulschließung
ausgangssperre welchen nutzen welchen
schaden von verantwortlichen öffentlich
immer das gleiche mantra
sehen dass also die kontakt maßnahmen
die wir in deutschland noch an platz
haben wirken die maßnahmen die ergriffen
worden sind werke die maßnahmen die
ergriffen worden sind wirken der leiter
des instituts für qualität und
wirtschaftlichkeit im gesundheitswesen
2004 gegründet mit unterstützung von
karl lauterbach nach analysen hat jedoch
auch er diese wissenschaftler nie
gefragt deutschland hat weiterhin im
dunkeln und hat sich sehr auf
plausibilitäten auf infektionsrisiken
auf eben massen sind davor und deswegen
schützen sie verlassen und hat sich sehr
relativ wenig insbesondere in
deutschland um die evidenz wie wir das
nennen gekümmert man hätte
wissenschaftlich genauer hinschauen
können zum beispiel als hamburg und
mecklenburg vorpommern die hotspot karte
zogen ab anfang april galten nur dort
schärfere maßnahmen doch die infektions
kurve verglichen mit dem rest des landes
verlief verblüffend ähnlich die region
in den hotspot regelungen dann
eingeführt worden sind im vergleich zu
dem oder es nicht gemacht wurde in den
letzten monaten sind letztlich von den
infektionszahlen ungefähr vergleichbar
das heißt man kann daraus ablesen dass
viele maßnahmen letztlich wenig gebracht
haben querstrich überzogen waren laut
infektionsschutzgesetz
soll die wirksamkeit der pandemie
bekämpfung bis ende juni
wissenschaftlich untersucht werden in
einem internen schreiben von lauterbach
an die parlamentspräsidentin bittet
ausgerechnet der zuständige minister der
den erfolg der maßnahmen öffentlich
anpreist um die verschiebung des termins
grund sei dass daten die detaillierte
aussagen über die wirksamkeit zu lassen
würden nicht oder nur in sehr
beschränktem maße vorlegen wir können
maßnahmen nur dann treffen wenn wir
belastbare datengrundlage haben das ist
auch verfassungsrechtlichen sehr sehr
hohes gut und jetzt quasi in dem dritten
herbst hinein zu laufen der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt wir
hätten nicht genügend daten gleichzeitig
wird aber auch nichts getan um diese
daten zu generieren was ja möglich wäre
das ist schon leicht absurd wer
infiziert sich wo welche vorteile haben
massnahmen welche nachteile wie hoch
sind die kollateralschäden
deutschland bleibt nur der blick über
den tellerrand
es gibt ja eine untersuchung über die
verschiedenen maßnahmen in verschiedenen
ländern und ist deutschland im
mittelfeld nicht ganz weit vorne andere
länder die nicht zu einschränkenden
maßnahmen vorgenommen haben die
beispielsweise schweden statt schneiden
nicht schlechter ab die schweiz
beispielsweise schneidet nicht
schlechter aber wohl sie auch kann ja
generell lockt angeordnet hat also man
muss schon vorsichtig sagen der
deutschen anmaßung wir sagen über die
besten trotz der mangel publiziert das
robert-koch-institut jede woche einen
bericht zur corona lage darin enthalten
eine tabelle über die infizierten doch
seitdem die mit abstand größte gruppe
die geposteten sind werden diese zahlen
nicht mehr veröffentlicht das rk ii das
den gesundheitsminister unterstellt ist
schreibt stattdessen diese daten seien
nicht geeignet um die wirksamkeit der
impfung einzuschätzen eine abkehr der
lauterbach vorsätze denn beim
amtsantritt betonte er wie wichtig
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse seien
die gesundheitspolitik aus meiner sicht
kann nur dann erfolgreich sein wenn sie
sich in der wissenschaft verankert
findet in der evidenzbasierten medizin
unzureichende daten kaum erkenntnisse
über wirkung und nebenwirkungen von
corona beschränkungen noch immer stolper
deutschland durch die pandemie